donc mes chers collègues nous commençons
nous poursuivons les travaux de notre
commission d'enquête sur la pénurie de
médicaments et les choix de l'industrie
pharmaceutique française ont des
changements avec Monsieur Heyman sabahi
président directeur général de
l'entreprise sociale égyptienne
Cham Seya vous me reproduisez mal
vous êtes bloqué
c'est mon accent
il n'est plus là
est-ce que vous nous entendez
oui maintenant je vous entends bien vous
m'entendez oui parfait
donc Président Directeur Général alors
je continue mon propos du coup président
directeur général de l'entreprise
sociale égyptienne chamseya dont l'objet
est je cite de développer des solutions
innovantes en matière de soins de santé
qui place le patient au cœur et au
centre des politiques sanitaires lors de
son audition pour notre commission
d'enquête l'Observatoire de la
transparence dans les politiques du
médicament
ôté meds a à plusieurs reprises fait
référence aux spécificités de la
politique du médicament en Égypte
notamment en matière de traitement
antiviraux
à action directe
antiviraux et la délivrance des brevets
de production publique de certains
médicaments dans le cas d'une réflexion
sur les laboration d'une stratégie
européenne de production des médicaments
d'intérêt thérapeutique majeurs madame
Pauline londex cofondera Thierry de
l'Observatoire a ainsi érigé des GIPS en
modèle je cite d'une production privée
mais réalisée en articulations très
intelligente avec les pouvoirs publics
et les bureaux des brevets avec une
volonté politique forte de faire accéder
la population à des médicaments vitaux
c'est en particulier pour sa réussite
dans la lutte contre l'hépatite C dans
un pays où la prévalence de la maladie
était la plus élevée au monde et pour sa
capacité à mettre à la disposition de sa
population le fameux Sophos buvir que
l'Égypte est souvent citée en exemple et
même devenu une destination de tourisme
médical
après que le Bureau des brevets
égyptiens a refusé d'accorder un brevet
au laboratoire gilet pour son sauvaldi
vendu à des prix exorbitants aux
États-Unis et en Europe le gouvernement
égyptien a opté en 2014 pour la
production locale de générique de ces
nouveaux traitements antiviraux à action
directe et parvenu à les fournir à des
coûts plus de 1000 fois inférieures à se
pratiquer dans certains pays à hauts
revenus à l'époque pour l'association
Sophos buvirde d'Atlas vire selon les
chiffres disponibles 120 dollars contre
147000 dollars aux États-Unis et 41.000
euros en France pour 12 semaines de
traitement ce qui fait une différence
quand même extrêmement
essentielle lors de la mise sur le
marché en France du sovaldi nombreux
étaient ceux qui réclamaient un débat
public sur la légitimité de certains
brevets sur l'utilisation de la licence
d'office outils juridique qui en France
bien qu'inscrit dans le Code de la
propriété intellectuelle n'a jamais été
mise en œuvre et ne pas pouvoir l'être
au dire des ministres de la Santé
successifs que nous avons auditionné et
qui nous ont confirmés cette réponse il
nous a donc paru intéressant d'échanger
avec vous pour évoquer les conditions
dans lesquelles une telle politique a pu
être mise en oeuvre dans votre pays et
dans quelle mesure les actions
entreprises en Égypte notamment en
matière d'accès à certains traitements
innovants pourraient être reproduites
pour d'autres traitements ou transposer
à d'autres pays comme la France
dont la disposition à payer est
évidemment très différente de celle de
l'Egypte de votre pays les dépenses de
santé sont infiniment moins socialisés
en Égypte qu'en France ceux qui certes
change la donne notamment du d'un point
de vue d'élaboratoires monsieur sabahi
sur ces sujets sur les spécificités et
limites du modèle égyptien je vais
immédiatement vous aider la parole pour
un bref propos introductif puis madame
Laurence Cohen qui est rapporteur de
notre commission d'enquête vous posera
une première question et ensuite je
transmettrai la parole à à nos collègues
je précise que cette audition est
diffusée en direct sur le site internet
du Sénat et qu'elle fera l'objet d'un
compte rendu publié mais ce sabaye je
vous remercie vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup c'est très
apprécié et j'espère que aujourd'hui je
pourrais même vous donner quelques
pistes pour votre travail très important
alors tout d'abord en fait je voulais
commencer mon propos sur un petit tout à
fait
des des conditions et des des
outils qui ont été employés par l'Egypte
par l'État égyptien mais aussi par la
société civile égyptienne
spécifiquement dans le cas des
médicaments
sur
l'hépatite C alors premièrement il faut
quand même
souligner que
avant 2014 l'Egypte était le pays
avec la plus grande
avec le plus grandes personnes
pourcentage de cas de hépatite dans le
monde
et et c'est vraiment c'était une une
infection qui est très répandue en
Égypte et en fait la raison principale
de ça c'était une campagne qui a été
menée par l'État égyptien dans les
années
50-60 voire même plus après pour
le traitement massif d'une autre a dit
qui s'appelait la biographie
[Musique]
d'une maladie qui était très répandue en
Egypte et dans le traitement dans les
années 50-60 ce qui faisait avec une
injection
du substance qui s'appelait le tartare
hermétique et à ce moment-là l'État
égyptien a décidé de faire une
intervention massive pour le traitement
de cette maladie là
donnant ces gens sections là et en ce
moment là c'est injection était faite
avec des sièges en glace qui ont été
lavés et donc des mesures
d'infection de prévention d'affection
très limitée et du coup avec cette
campagne là ils ont répondu l'hépatite C
par tout dans le pays c'est vraiment
gérer par cette campagne
du gouvernement et avec le défi
d'information sur le mode de
transmission de les petites ci pendant
ce moment-là et donc c'était vraiment la
responsabilité de l'État de retrouver
une solution pour l'hépatite C
en avant l'année 2014 l'État égyptien a
commencé à entendre
voilà des annonces de différents
sur la production de nouvelles gammes
dont virus qui voilà qui promettait des
voilà des résultats
très encourageantes et pour pouvoir
taper sur ce marché très important pour
eux bien sûr une il devait faire des
tests cliniques des essais cliniques en
Égypte sur des patients égyptiens tout
d'abord
s'assurer que le génotype de l'hépatite
C qui était incendie en Égypte voilà que
que ce traitement aller
apporter de bons résultats avec ce
génotype là et deuxièmement parce que
voilà c'est c'est le marché le plus
important pour eux et donc du coup une
grande partie des essais cliniques sur
ce médicament là a été conduite en
Égypte
avec la coopération du gouvernement et
donc quand le
con voilà les résultats étaient positifs
et que les
il y a et d'autres entreprises plus tard
ont voulu voilà entrer en négociations
avec le gouvernement ça c'était un très
grand point d'appui
et c'était très important en fait dans
le processus de la négociation
une deuxième chose c'est que l'Egypte
a décidé d'utiliser plusieurs
processus plusieurs outils dans ces
négociations avec
l'Iliade et d'autres campagnes d'abord
il y aide avait un délai il y avait un
deadline avec la
aux États-Unis et il savait que d'autres
compagnies pharmaceutiques avaient
d'autres produits similaires qui voilà
était la première entreprise qui avait
obtenu
le permis de la FDA mais il savait très
bien que d'autres compagnies allaient
les suivre et donc c'est très important
de taper dans le marché assez rapidement
et c'était une pression très importante
la deuxième chose c'est que pour les
tailles égyptien
l'État est
le le premier
voilà comment dire ou la première le
premier
[Musique]
français c'est pas
acheteur le premier
là voilà le premier acheteur de ces
produits c'était le gouvernement parce
que il voulait mettre en disposition ces
médicaments là dans les hôpitaux publics
et
donc voilà
pour que ça fasse partie de l'assurance
publique et tout ça et donc c'est très
important pour eux que ils puissent
arriver à des prix voilà très
très
possible pour eux d'acheter et la
condition pour eux c'est que on va
ajouter
une certaine quantité de ces produits là
à un prix très réduit
et au bout d'un certain moment
l'entreprise pourra aussi vendre ce
médicament là dans les pharmacies du
point de vue privé voilà donc les gens
pourront toujours les acheter
alors aise mais dans ce cas-là ils
auront plus de liberté dans le
sur le sujet du prix de ces médicaments
et donc c'était un petit peu un
compromis entre l'entreprise et le
gouvernement le troisième point qui
était très important c'est que la
société civile a joué un rôle très
important dans ces négociation là tout
d'abord et j'ai eu la chance de faire
partie de ce groupe là la société civile
a eu des réunions avec
l'entreprise Guyane parce que ils leur
ont fourni des évidences sur le vrai
coût de la production de ces médicaments
là et donc c'était très possible de leur
donner de l'évidence de leur donner des
informations sur le vrai coût et de leur
dire
vous devez quand même baisser le prix
parce que ça sera pas possible en Égypte
de vendre à ce prix là au bout de au
même moment il y avait des
voilà des cas qui étaient
en Inde des des voilà des cas civils et
des
comment dire
et
le processus légal en Inde pour établir
avoir si
ces médicaments là seront considérés
comme de nouvelles technologies et donc
s'ils auront une Beatles ou
une licence exclusive de production
comme un nouveau produit ou est-ce que
ça va être considéré comme produit
générique et donc les pays courant le
fabriquer à l'oreille avec des prix qui
leur sont condolables et encore on dit
non en fait ces efforts là avec notre
société civile en Inde dans ces cas-là
on Inde ils ont eu un
la décision voilà de tribunal c'est que
non c'était pas vraiment un produit
très original c'était une évolution de
technologie qui était déjà présente et
donc on va pas lui accorder
le copyright
ils changent d'être exclués
a pu mettre sur la table l'option de
voilà écoutez on va utiliser l'outil
refuse pricing ou le prix de référence
ce qui veut dire que on a le droit de
prendre le prix qui avait accordé par
notre pays comme l'Inde par exemple et
le dire ben écoutez si vous ne donnez
pas ce prix là on pourra voilà de
produire localement en utilisant toutes
les spéculations de
type agril
et
la
déclarations
ce sont des mécanismes internationaux
qui peuvent être utilisés pour tout ce
qui est santé publique et la production
de médicaments très important pour la
santé
et donc avec tous ces outils là avec
toute la pression qui a été exercée par
la société civil égyptienne participer
international en utilisant des outils
comme comme
solidarisensement obligatoire le prix de
référence et tout ça l'État a pu obtenir
voilà ces prix et a pu aussi
produire ça comme produit générique en
dessous donc c'est un petit tour aperçu
de différents outils et je peux bien sûr
on peut en parler plus avec plus de
détails selon vos questions
très bien merci beaucoup pour pour ces
éléments je vais tout de suite passer la
parole à Laurence Cohen rapporteur pour
des questions complémentaires et puis
ensuite à ceux qui le souhaitent
pour voilà avoir un échange pour suivre
l'échange avec vous
merci Monsieur pour vos propos
introductifs alors effectivement
peut-être quelques questions par rapport
aux éléments que vous nous avez apporté
qui sont extrêmement intéressants donc
en fait vous l'Égypte est confronté à
l'hépatite C de manière extrêmement
forte et à partir de là donc vous vous
êtes amené à trouver des solutions ce
que vous nous avez ce que vous nous avez
décrit alors ma première ma première
question c'est est-ce que à partir de
cette expérience concernant donc le
traitement de l'hépatite C vous avez été
en capacité de développer ces mêmes
stratégies pour d'autres médicaments
sachant que en Égypte si je ne me trompe
pas la prise en charge des traitements
un comble aux patients
donc il n'y a pas par exemple comme en
France une prise en charge de de la
sécurité sociale qui fait que les les
traitements sont accessibles normalement
à tout et à tous quel que soit le
territoire donc est-ce que vous avez été
en capacité donc de reproduire en
quelque sorte cette cette méthode pour
d'autres médicaments si tel et le cas
dans quelle médicament ma deuxième
question c'est à partir du moment où
vous avez donc
inscrit un modèle extrêmement
intéressant et qui permet aux patients
égyptiens d'avoir accès donc à ces
médicaments est-ce que vous avez pu
avoir des des entreprises qui sur le
territoire égyptien ont pu produire ces
médicaments et quand je dis produire ces
médicaments je veux parler parce que
c'est une difficulté qu'on a en Europe
et singulièrement en en France du
principe actif jusqu'au produit aux
produits finis et ma troisième et
dernière question c'est est-ce que vous
pensez à la lumière de votre de votre
expérience que ce
modèle que vous avez mis en place
serait exportable c'est ce qu'elle dit
d'ailleurs la présidente au niveau de
pays industriels comme la France mais
pour l'ensemble de l'Europe nous je dois
dire qu'on sorte beaucoup à au secret
des affaires à
la au brevet comme quand je dis nous
c'est le problème des brevets et de la
propriété intellectuelle c'est c'est un
frein pour l'ensemble des pays au niveau
mondial d'accès aux thérapies donc voilà
voilà les questions les trois questions
que je voulais vous poser je vous
remercie par avance de vos réponses
vous avez la parole
alors je vais commencer en fait par
faire une petite précision le système de
santé en Égypte alors selon les
statistiques nationales on parle de à
peu près 63% de la population qui ont
droit à l'assurance maladie publique qui
est ouvert par l'État donc c'est
relativement une un grand pourcentage de
la population par contre le taux
d'utilisation de ces services n'est pas
très haut et c'est ça le problème on va
aussi une tendance à faire des dépenses
sur les services de santé qu'on appelle
Out Of Poker ou voilà des poches des
patients et c'est pour ça que il y a un
grand pourcentage des dépenses qui sont
voilà sur qui sont dépensés directement
par les patients pour leur famille mais
n'empêche que par exemple en ce qui
concerne les médicaments de l'hépatite C
ils ont été pratiquement exclusivement
fourni par l'État
à travers le système de santé nationale
et donc il y a 3 ans l'État égyptien a
conduit une campagne nationale pour la
détection et le diagnose de l'hépatite C
et puis du traitement gratuit des
patients-là et maintenant l'état Égypte
la fournit il y a
quelques mois un rapport qui dit que
l'Egypte et sur le point de pouvoir
annoncer qu'elle a complètement errer et
qu'il a complètement éradiqué l'hépatite
C
à cause de ses campagnes là et ces
médicaments là ils ont été achetés par
l'État et non pas par les patients donc
il y a des mécanismes avec une certaine
similarité avec le système d'assurance
République en France surtout en ce qui
concerne
l'achat de grande quantités de
médicaments pour pouvoir assurer
secrètement là tout d'abord et donc je
vais vous peut-être répondre sur votre
deuxième question ici l'État a donné la
licence à plusieurs entreprises de
produire ces médicaments là en Égypte
donc c'est plusieurs entreprises
il y a commencé mais il y avait d'autres
plusieurs entreprises qui ont aussi pu
produire leurs médicaments dans par
exemple de l'entreprise MSD et autres et
puis l'État à travers ces entreprises et
ses
usines nationaux ils ont aussi pu
produire ces médicaments là avec des
entreprises et des usines qui sont
gérées par l'État
d'abord c'était vraiment une question de
voilà de
la dernière partie de la production tout
ce qui est emballage et tout ça le
processus au début
n'était pas la production complète des
médicaments et puis voilà de plus en
plus l'état
accordé des facilitations qui pour qui
ont permis la production de d'une voilà
une partie
de plus en plus grande des matières
primaires et des médicaments donc pour
le moment c'était c'était ça vraiment
l'idée
en ce qui concerne si ça a été
systémique là aussi ces outils là on
peut aller dans d'autres médicaments oui
effectivement c'est quelque chose
maintenant qui est devenu une règle et
l'Egypte en fait a créé
un dispositif
gouvernemental donc une département ou
plutôt une institution qui est
directement gérée par l'État
qui est en charge de
je veux dire simplement en anglais mais
le procurement
massif de tout ce qui est médicament et
technologie médicale et maintenant
pour pouvoir
avoir des médicaments dans les hôpitaux
publics dans les cliniques
ils doivent se procurer tous les
médicaments et tous les dispositifs
médicaux à travers ce processus qui
permet donc de d'avoir des prix
très basses parce que c'est une
négociation de masse c'est comme on
disait tous les hôpitaux publics de
l'État vont acheter les médicaments une
seule fois avec un
donc très compétitif et donc c'est un
processus qui qui a été utilisé et là il
utilise tous les outils donc ils
utilisent qu'on parle sur les license
obligatoire
tout ce qui peut être utilisés pour la
négociation dans les dans le triple ou
dans
tout ça pour pouvoir se procurer la
technologie et les médicaments de point
de vue national et l'exception c'est que
quand ils ont besoin de voilà d'acheter
ces produits là
voilà d'une façon plus simple
un autre point très important c'est que
l'Egypte en utilisant ces techniques là
ils ont pu en fait aussi produit des
médicaments par exemple dans le
traitement de des atrophies musculaires
ce sont des médicaments qui sont très
chers voilà c'est c'est ça coûte des
millions de de
livres égyptienne et c'était
exclusivement produit par des
entreprises américaines en général même
et donc c'était vraiment à des prix
exorbitants et quand l'Egypte a mis dans
sa constitution que l'État fournir
un système d'assurance au public des
choses à prendre du temps ça prendra au
moins 15 ans pour la réalisation
complète de système de couverture
universelle de la santé mais quand ils
ont mis ça en place
l'O de l'État envers ses patients a
commencé à augmenter et donc l'Egypte a
pu récemment produire ces produits là
localement avec des prix aussi qui sont
100 fois 200 fois moins que les prix
global mais c'était toujours une
question de d'initiative
de l'État avec une pression de la
société civile et un pouvoir
d'utilisation
prenons encore que l'Egypte n'a pas de
problème
à utiliser des des voilà des des outils
comme les flexibilités de la trips
agrile
et ça je comprends que la France
serait plus réservé à utiliser ça
surtout quand c'est une question de
brevet avec la pression qui peut être
mise de point de vue des entreprises et
des compagnies pharmaceutiques
[Musique]
monsieur sabaye pour que nous
comprenions bien vous êtes en capacité
de discuter mais aussi parce que
vous pouvez opposer au laboratoire dans
la discussion la capacité à produire
dans votre pays les médicaments en
question ça c'est ma première question
et ma deuxième question
repose sur le fait que vous pouvez pas
faire ça pour tous les médicaments donc
il y a forcément une stratégie c'est il
faut une situation de crise ou
une criticité particulière du médicament
concerné ou de la pathologie concernée
pour vous décidiez de mettre en oeuvre
ce process
oui alors tout d'abord c'est beaucoup
plus facile avec les médicaments qui
sont utilisés dans le cas de prise ou du
public massif comme le cas par exemple
d'hépatite C je deviens beaucoup plus
compliqué dans les médicaments qui
traitent un nombre assez limité de
patients bien sûr mais la plupart du
temps ces grandes négociations c'est
grandes initiatives qui vont pousser les
entreprises soit à produits en Egypte
soit à donner des licences à d'autres
entreprises pour la population locale ça
vient vraiment de la présidence dans
certains cas et et ça arrive parfois
aussi dans le cas par exemple
des médicaments pour les attitudes
musculaires ou c'était vraiment une
initiative présidentielle de de
production et là les négociations
étaient vraiment très de haut niveau
donc c'est une pression parfois
parce-que
comme ressources
bien sûr parfois c'est pas possible de
fournissent les médicaments là
aux patient et donc c'est aussi
important de souligner que
cette question source et une grande
partie de la négociation
sont des entreprises d'initiatives
publiques ou
voilà je crois que c'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre c'est à dire que
l'exécutif décide que il y a une
entreprise qui enfin une usine qui se
met en place pour produire tel
médicament ça se fait avec le
laboratoire en lien avec le laboratoire
j'imagine et qui trouve un intérêt aussi
à pouvoir produire au travers de cette
usine ou est-ce qu'il vous est arrivé ou
est-ce que vous êtes en capacité d'avoir
une production exclusivement public
c'est-à-dire déconnecté finalement de du
laboratoire qui avait le brevet au
départ
de pression pour les entreprises là
aussi en Égypte il y a une loi
pour qui donne bien sûr à l'état le
droit de de décider des prix des
médicaments qui sont vendus au grand
public et donc l'État a le droit de
gérer le prix directement et et ce sont
des décisions et des calculs voilà
l'état il ne laisse pas ça complètement
à la guise du marché et donc voilà c'est
vraiment l'État a beaucoup d'outils
qu'il peut utiliser d'un point de vue
légal pour vraiment aboutir à des prix
qui sont plutôt convenables et face à
une demande assez grande des entreprises
parfois n'ont pas le choix
j'ai une question complémentaire d'une
collègue Laurence Harris
bonjour et merci de cet éclairage parce
que c'est important de sortir un peu de
la situation franco-française pour pour
comprendre
un petit peu les problèmes que les
questions qu'on se pose je voudrais
revenir sur sur deux choses la première
vous avez dit dans votre propos
liminaire que
l'État avait cherché un
mesurer le vrai coup du médicament
comment vous avez fait très précisément
et du coup comme vous venez de nous dire
que c'était le gouvernement qui fixait
les prix comment vous allez élaborer
vous décidez que le prix est le bon prix
ça c'est la première la première
question et la deuxième question si j'ai
bien compris mais peut-être que j'ai mal
compris en fait vous avez développé une
une industrie locale et une production
locale par la distribution de licence
et donc l'autorisation à produire avec
un prix qui est un prix fixé par par
l'État
avec le recul ça a donné lieu à
finalement quelle structuration de
l'industrie pharmaceutique en Egypte
est-ce qu'on a beaucoup de petites PME
ou est-ce que ce sont des grandes
entreprises est-ce que vous pouvez nous
donner un éclairage là dessus
merci
à vous alors en fait il y avait une
étude qui a été
conduite par
je vais essayer de vous envoyer quand
même le lien
par des partenaires de la société civile
globale sur le vrai coût de la
production et on a présenté ça comme
société civile dans le ressenti avec
qu'il y a comme un point de négociation
et dans cette étude là il a été estimé
que
la dose de médicaments que il y a
vendait à 3600 dollars écoutez en fait à
peu près 250 dollars pour le coup de
voilà du cours complet de traitement et
on leur a montré cette étude là avec
des détails de comment ça a été calculé
et puis on a présenté ça aussi au
gouvernement qui ont utilisé cette étude
là bien sûr
la validité la précision de ces études
là ça a besoin de de ressources quand
même assez grande mais ça a été ils
n'ont pas vraiment pu
voilà ils n'ont pas ils n'ont pas donné
de
d'autres informations donc ce qu'on fait
en fait c'est qu'on leur dit ben écoutez
on a trouvé cette étude là et voilà on
leur montre qui dit que le prix de
production et le thème est-ce que vous
voyez des choses autrement et là ils
sont contraints soit à nous donner bah
voilà les détails pour refuser un petit
peu
au prix qui a été présenté dans cet
outil là soit ils doivent l'accepter et
dans ce cas là ils l'ont accepté
et puis le gouvernement alors ils ont
utilisé ça pour pouvoir pousser un petit
peu dans ce dans cette direction
mais mais en général les les il y a des
des institutions nationaux comme par
exemple aux États-Unis
[Musique]
au Royaume-Uni ils ont
le MI c e
je pense aussi en France que il y a pas
mal d'institutions qui font ce qu'on
appelle
les suivis ou le rapport de
[Musique]
traduction française très triste pour ça
mais s'appelle
et en fait sont des institutions
nationaux qui font ces études là et qui
peuvent fournir des informations non
seulement sur les coûts de production
mais aussi sur
le rapport entre le coût des médicaments
et le résultat clinique et tous ces
informations là c'est ces nombres ils
peuvent très bien être utilisés à
pousser les négociations
donc ça c'est le premier point
tu peux me rappeler très rapidement
est-ce que cette finalement le système
de de développement d'une industrie
pharmaceutique en distribuant des
licences ça a donné quel paysage et
quelle structuration de l'industrie
pharmaceutique en Égypte bon alors
très varié il y a des entreprises
internationaux qui font le production
ici il y a aussi des entreprises
publics qui sont gérés par l'État et
parfois voilà c'est vraiment une
combinaison des deux donc le problème
bien sûr c'est que avec la loi qui gère
les prix des médicaments parfois c'est
assez compliqué pour ces entreprises là
à
travailler et parfois ça vaut pas le
coup et on a eu des pénuries dans des
médicaments qui sont très importants par
exemple dans les médicaments sur pour
les
tout ce qui est les morphines par
exemple pour la gestion de de
peine et des mots dans les cas les
cancers très avancés et tout ça et ça
parce que
les restrictions légales et on se dit ce
qui concerne les prix n'était pas
favorable
pour les entreprises privées à produire
le médicament et donc ils ont arrêté
mais là le gouvernement intervient par
une production publique à travers ses
usines
et donc c'est un environnement qui n'est
pas toujours très favorable au secteur
privé parce que voilà c'est c'est
assez
fortement
régulier par
l'état du positif public mais il y a
toujours voilà un compromis parce que
ces entreprises là ils trouvent qu'on
Egypte il y a quand même un trophée
élevé de paiement de coût sur la santé
d'une façon privée et puis il y a un
nombre de patients et donc ils peuvent
pas
mais il est vraiment il y a tout il y a
c'est un secteur qui est très fluide
maintenant et
il y a de plus en plus de rôles de
l'État dans la production des
médicaments
très bien encore une seule question
Emilienne Poumirol
oui merci pour tous ces tous ces
renseignements je comprends bien surtout
avec ce que vous venez de dire à
l'instant qui a un rôle majeur de l'État
et j'ai bien compris qu'on
l'exemple de l'hépatite C c'est un
médicament qui est particulièrement cher
et qui bon il se trouve que l'Égypte
avait beaucoup d'hépatite C donc c'était
il y avait un marché qui était important
mais est-ce que vous en dehors des
médicaments j'allais dire de de crise ou
en tout cas ce type de médicament est-ce
que pour des molécules aussi simples que
le parastamol ou l'amoxicilline ou nous
subissons-nous des pénuries est-ce que
vous avez aussi une production nationale
qui vous est propre quoi même sur des
médicaments alors c'est sûr que c'est
l'état fixer les prix ça modifie un peu
à donner mais est-ce que vous avez une
production locale de médicaments ce que
nous on appelle les médicaments matures
c'est à dire bon certainement
médicaments relativement anciens qui
sont produits en Égypte
oui effectivement il y a une table il y
a une grande production locale de ces
molécules là
l'État intervient
à l'intérieur pas pour faire une
production publique à travers les usines
de l'État que sauf quand le secteur
privé n'arrive pas à répondre aux
besoins on a eu ce cas par exemple dans
la production de
des formules voilà des du lait
artificiel pour les enfants qui voilà
qui dépendent de ça au lieu de de
de l'allaitement naturel au bout d'un
certain moment il y a eu un déficit de
point de vue du secteur privé et donc le
gouvernement il a commencé à produire
voilà c'est c'est produit là mais en
général on peut aussi qu'on concerne les
médicaments par exemple pour
l'hypertension le diabète tout ce qui
est voilà de molécules comme le
paracétamol par exemple c'est en général
produit par des compagnies locales qui
arrivent à trouver un bon compromis
entre
une production qui leur donne quand même
du profit avec
la loi qui leur voilà impose un certain
prix pour les médicaments mais aussi en
maison la capacité de détendre leur
marché il arrive à la fin à avoir
toujours par rapport à à ce que est-ce
que vous dites en fait est-ce que les
entreprises donc qui sont
égyptiennes
en fait
répondent uniquement aux besoins de la
population égyptienne où est-ce que ces
mêmes entreprises sont capables d'aller
au-delà de l'Egypte
peut-être sans vouloir rivaliser avec ce
qui se passe en Europe mais peut-être
dans des pays à bas à bas revenu donc
est-ce que ça c'est une politique qui
est qui est menée et ma deuxième
question
d'après mon d'après ce que j'ai compris
donc en fait il y a une production
publique quand le privé ne répond pas
aux besoins donc il y a une il y a deux
secteurs en fait qui qui coexistent
c'est un secteur privé un secteur public
mais le sentiment quand même c'est que
les lois voire même la Constitution
permet
d'asseoir l'intervention publique et que
le pilote dans l'avion c'est l'état
oui effectivement l'état il joue un rôle
très important et à la fin le dernier
mot c'est vraiment le mot de l'État
alors il y a
une production qui commence à l'Égypte
et puis après qui qui voilà qui peut
être
des médicaments qui peuvent être
exportés en dehors de l'Egypte
particulièrement dans les pays d'Afrique
par exemple et lors de la production des
vaccins pour le covid par exemple
ça faisait une grande partie de la
stratégie de l'État et l'État veut que
l'Egypte soit un point central pour la
production des médicaments surtout dans
le continent africain
pas vraiment comme le cas de l'Inde ou
voilà il y a pas suffisamment de respect
de tout ce qui est
brevet et voilà et droit de ce qui
concerne la production de médicaments
mais quand même l'État égyptien veut
voilà se centrer sur cette stratégie qui
pourra un jour nous permettre d'être le
fournisseur le plus important des
médicaments dans le fonctionnement dans
le continent africain mais par exemple
dans le cas des traitements pour
l'hépatite C
ce prix là que l'Egypte a pu assurer lui
a permis d'avoir des campagnes et de
projets
pour le tourisme médical qui permet aux
gens aux patients d'autres pays de venir
en Égypte et de prendre le traitement
contre l'hépatite C parce qu'aussi
il y a une certaine restriction bien sûr
à l'entrée des médicaments en Égypte et
à la sortie surtout quand ce sont des
prix qui sont parfois
par l'État parce qu'il y a des
médicaments que l'État
support et parfois les conditions pour
la négociation avec les différents
entreprises ils ont comme conditions qui
n'ont pas le droit de fournissent des
médicaments on a en dehors de l'Egypte
avec ces prix là bien évidemment
et parfois même c'est très important
c'est pour ça que l'état parfois achète
les médicaments à des prix très bas
comme
voilà
comme une
comme le premier ou le plus important
fournisseur de ces médicaments là au
patients mais le prix référent le reste
qui peut être utilisé par cette
entreprise dans notre pays sera toujours
les prix de ces médicaments là qui sont
disponibles aux gens dans les pharmacies
et que ils vont devoir
les payer avec voilà donc leur argent
pas à travers les outils de de l'État ou
l'assurance publique par exemple et donc
vraiment c'est une balance très
importante entre
voilà les
positionnement que l'Egypte veut avoir
en ce qui concerne
les médicaments
dans l'Afrique et dans d'autres pays
mais de l'autre côté aussi leur rapport
et leur relation et de contrats qu'ils
ont avec les entreprises et les
consonnes il y a encore une question si
de Corinne Imbert moi juste une petite
vous êtes en situation de pénurie en ce
moment pour un certain nombre de
médicaments on parle de l'insuline
vous confirmez ou pas et je vais je vais
laisser la parole à Corinne Imbert avant
pour qu'elle pose la question mais aussi
pour merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur pour pour tout ce que vous nous
avez pour votre éclairage
j'aurais voulu évoquer avec vous le ce
qui est appelé gypto pharmaceity ou la
médecine City
selon les informations dont je les
connaissances quelque chose qui remonte
à plus de 7 ans enfin qui a mis du temps
à germer qui a été inauguré il y a deux
ans et selon le
[Musique]
selon le alors je recherche la qualité
de la personne le porte-parole de la
présidence 97% des médicaments des
besoins médicaments de la population
égyptienne serait produite par le pays
est-ce que vous confirmez cette
affirmation moi je pense que c'est le le
désir c'est le plan c'est voilà c'est
c'est l'aspiration mais ça vraiment le
cas pour le moment
c'est vraiment ça ça correspond plutôt
aux aspirations de l'état d'être
indépendant de point de vue la
disposition voilà celle ça fait comment
dire
suffisamment couvert
sans que ça soit dépendant de voilà
d'autres facteurs mais c'est pas encore
le cas
toujours voilà le développement merci
beaucoup et sur la pénurie actuelle
notamment d'insuline mais comment ça se
passe parce que vous êtes comme les
autres pays il y a quand même des
moments de pénurie
mais mais très rarement
c'est c'est
on voit pas toujours ça de point de vue
de grand public
immédiatement parce que l'État
intervient assez rapidement donc
vraiment c'est pas une pénurie de
l'incision en général mais c'est une
pénurie d'un certain type d'insuline
parce que parfois le voilà les
médicaments qui sont fournis par les
systèmes d'assurance publique par
exemple il ne correspondent pas toujours
aux
à ce que les les patients expectent et
parfois cette technique de licence et de
production locale
il donne soit l'impression soit parfois
même c'est le c'est vraiment le cas en
réalité que les médicaments qui sont
produits ne sont pas de la qualité que
les gens dans les gens ont besoin et
donc quand même dans certains cas
acheter les médicaments eux-mêmes à des
prix qui sont assez élevés pour
s'assurer que ça va être que ça va avoir
le même valeur médicale bien sûr l'état
des fonds que c'est la même
molécule primaire que ce sont les mêmes
ingrédients principal et qu'il n'y a pas
de différence mais voilà les patients
parfois
ont d'autres expériences pratiques en
d'autres
besoin c'est à ce sujet et donc les
pèleries elles viennent vraiment de ce
sujet là ne se sont pas des pèleries qui
sont pas des conneries globales qui
affectent tout le pays et qui cause le
problème on en parle même pas dans les
médias tout ça c'est toujours géré assez
rapidement par l'État avec voilà des
techniques de ce genre là
bien merci merci beaucoup voilà de de
cet échange très complet et enfin je
pense que votre témoignage était
intéressant
voilà parce que c'est c'est aussi une
découverte cette capacité à produire
autant de médicaments en Égypte et puis
cette stratégie quand même vers 98%
d'autonomie ce qui est quand même
très significatif à l'heure où on parle
de souveraineté
dans le domaine du médicament en Europe
notamment pour nous et pour pour nos
pays au niveau français merci merci
beaucoup merci à vous vraiment plaisir
et je suis à votre disposition merci au
revoir monsieur au revoir